non pourquoi vous avez une question si 241 à l'
étang au bureau avant les portes si je suis un
serveur Oliver chaque Yankee revient à ce
numéro pour le faire et rouler bébé
vient de demander notre objectif 1511 nous f30 1030
1020 Appa maintenant il y aura  soyez un
délinquant routier Roger pour vous offrir à nos
lecteurs
bravo Bravo les garçons ont posé leur
question 2433 pour trois numéros nous avons eu l'
hélicoptère vers elle vers neuf heures
de ce
trafic nucléaire aucun problème si vous lisez
très élégant et aérien avec
des tours de contrôle du corps maison élection de
phrases ironiques de la fortune 500 altimétrie 0 1
0 0 KY se demande pourquoi je veux le dos
allez fille nous ne pouvons pas te reconnaître oh oui
Peter  rit à travers 13 ici Roger
cosa Je veux le réservoir avec le
bâtiment pouvons-nous le faire si
c'est de quel côté c'est aussi l'angle nous devons être
un peu en arrière alors hé faites-le ici ce
qui va bien d'accord quels bâtiments vous voulez de la
viande c  contre ceux sur un chiot comme
ceux-ci de chaque côté de Parker oh
qu'il a dit est de l'autre côté cela
pour moi giltia province remarquera qu'ils
peuvent faire merci juste en s'assurant que nous pensons tous
les mêmes choses ouais
ouais un autre sera  sur la station entre
le rivage des
années 2000 purvis a demandé à
1470 Republic pour un flip 180 pour euh
finir en direction du sud sur la rivière jusqu'à la
peur de la forêt de peupliers quelle affaire
vous pensez de ce quelque chose comme ça
ouais non où est le réservoir probablement
autour du pit-bull c'est alors tout  le
reste plus tard, je sais qu'avec un Terran,
nous allons obtenir un coup de HR 4400 complet sur notre
album, mais une fois, c'est un appel cool pour
cet article archive les années 1500 m230 10
trafic onze heures une bouche ouverte à l'
extérieur de toute façon 900 si  ils peuvent être un
visuel c'est pourquoi les trafiquants étaient
donc alpha pour que les photos sur
facebook ou propriété ne vous offrent pas
1 500 symétrie 010 trafic onze
heures deux milles dans la direction
absolue indique 904 [ __ ] mais un
m  ile nord lors d'une tournée notre
premier gagnant de l'hélicoptère focus vient à vous
comme ça et ensuite nous le ferons juste un
gros plan du réservoir et je le présente
à l'arrière d'accord pouvons-nous voler supposons que nous
vivons dans la direction de l'heure si nous y allons  ouais
Californie 12 là-bas qui aime la
répétition du terrain Ruby au centre, allez sur le
parcours de golf du directeur se réfère à approuver et comme vous le
faites, BTW a ramassé je n'ai pas pu trouver
ses petites eaux à 800, c'était que pour la
conduite funky à travers les touches je ne peux pas  frapper
un effet de fille pourquoi est-ce que c'est bizarre pourquoi
parce que nous allons contrôler leur
origine pour le trajet ah non pas occupé d'accord
allez le à bravo Bravo contact
approche proche sur un à 0,8 0,8 préfère
républicain
juste sur les bâtiments ouais je '  je vais directement
au pont ouais
mais les bords sont une limite de cette façon vous
devez vous arrêter là d'accord
l'extrémité défensive
vérifiant les 6 sujets à nouveau que
Susan Broman lance sur la
passerelle en ciment de la proposition d'
un bâtiment orange ici Dorothy qui est
sur votre couverture l'année dernière  bien
le  re est une paire à droite pensez-vous
que si cela va à une radio sorte de
haineux viajes il sera vraiment facile d'
accord c'est dans quelle direction nous l'obtiendrons
alors nous allons nous diriger vers le bas de
la rivière  quoi ouais tôt parti d'ici
nous allons faire un autre ensemble du
parc central chaque loi est un occupant
du réservoir meilleure antenne à droite d'
accord rendez-le à environ 4 430 rapide
donc nous avons terminé le réservoir pensé d'
accord mais ensuite nous  pensé que ça marcherait
ou autre chose 44 hé ce que je resterai
pour la fête des Southsiders oh il a vraiment
montré beaucoup de choses à quelqu'un 9 fonction hôtelière de
gaudiya tour 40 à 44 crédit abolir le
demandé une fois que votre moteur s'est arrêté
moteur sur un pont maintenir 1500 tous
similaires  pour réduire votre propre article a une
jolie syrienne sur terre 024 formats pour
et
dessiner
nous pourrions faire un cercle là-bas lorina
ne peut pas rester debout pour descendre huit cents
et ensuite je peux reprendre le reste des
bâtiments à nouveau
les papas ici  un contrat milltown une fois
2025  est-ce un point si je ferais mieux d'
aller voir ton papa prends soin de toi
et aime un tel spectacle que le
parc est au milieu de la ville
es-tu
42 d'accord nous ne pouvons pas faire continuer un gars a couru
vers la droite allons-nous tous  ensemble, réveillez-
vous dans la manière de répondre à la conception de fonctionnalités
beaucoup de preuves avant d'apprécier approuver de
vous faire aimer une citation en tant que raciste vous
ne pouvez pas aller à Central Park dans beaucoup ouais à
venir ouais
recommencer ouais Merci le week
-end c'est  pourquoi ils ne veulent pas tourner
aujourd'hui pas à propos de cette chose qui se passe sur la
musique eh bien nous ne pourrons
pas rester ici longtemps d'accord jetez-nous d'accord
eh bien dieter juste pour garder le côté finir
ça vous taquine à propos des bâtiments qui montent
aux bâtiments qu'est-ce qu'on fait
autour ouais juste un petit lit ou Dieu
vient ici Le clan Isabella ne devrait pas
juste traverser la rivière pas sous
le soleil tellement
continuer comme ça euh Peter Thompson et lui
tu peux aller où tu es où le ferait  tu
aimes y aller j'aimerais y aller c'est vraiment
brumeux peut r  éduquer des plans verticaux des
bâtiments ici marcher dans la brume ouais
Charlie quelques photos font la promotion de nos garçons sont
remplis pour Charlie plus tôt cet endroit
d'une année de rêve je dois être autorisé
à descendre d'accord je vais flic pour emmener notre
fille avec l'esprit fait ici quand  allons-nous
descendre 1800 en bas vers
waynesburg riche pour penser au saut
hors de la boucle ami des années 2000 qui fonctionne
très bien nous allons travailler sur la
station entre South Central Park et
Williamsburg Bridge Je serai bien pour
un peu Delta  vous que diriez-vous d'un coup porté à des
milliers de personnes, merci, je veux
avoir de vrais arguments,
oh ouais quand je vais dans la ville, je postule
directement depuis le pont George Washington Bridge
59th Street haha je suis à côté de l'ONU
et elle  J'ai toujours voulu que je monte
ce petit stade Yankee au lit de la rivière,
n'importe quel domaine particulier que vous voulez bien faire
directement dans quelque chose ou autre
, certains allons-nous être
joués à ce qui se passe hé loin, nous sommes clairs
pour vous d'accord allez à droite  au-dessus de
cette chose, nous faisons beaucoup de RF comme
l'e2 autour de non oh on y va ici je vais
juste au-dessus d'un feu ouais ouais littéralement
ouais je veux dire que c'est un endroit emblématique
il y a de nombreuses années, j'ai demandé à ma vie que
Je divorce et j'épouse Leona Helmsley en
ce moment on s'en sortirait plutôt bien